hello and welcome to math simplified i'm
dr umar malik and i'm back today with
another interesting video
in our previous videos we have discussed
about smoking and how to detox your
lungs from the damage caused by smoking
we also discussed about a few natural
ways to help your lungs recover from the
damage caused by smoking
i encourage you to watch that video
first
the link to that video will be displayed
in the top left corner of the screen
right
now our lungs are essential for our
survival so taking good care of them is
really important for us but elements
like smoking and living in a polluted
environment affects them very negatively
before we go deeper into the video i
would like to remind all of you that
smoking is considered as a global
pandemic as tobacco use kills 5 million
citizens globally every year
the world health organization projects
the number of deaths will double just 15
years from now
as i mentioned in my previous videos
smoking is a leading cause of
preventable deaths in the world
if you smoke you are effectively
decreasing your life by 10 years or more
but smoking and pollution are not the
only reasons why lung diseases are
getting very common
lots of people find it hard to breathe
because there is inflammation in their
lungs this can be due to diseases like
asthma chronic obstructive pulmonary
disease pulmonary fibrosis or even from
lung cancers
while foods have not been proven to heal
or treat such diseases research has
found that lifestyle changes like
following a healthy diet and getting
enough exercise can definitely help in
lung health and recovery
a healthy well-balanced diet goes a long
way to keep your body strong including
your lungs
in this video i will tell you about some
super foods that if included in your
diet can substantially boost your lung
recovery and eventually give you
healthier lungs so let's begin
the number one food we are gonna discuss
is turmeric
turmeric is a well-known superfood
turmeric's potential as a powerful
antioxidant and anti-inflammatory food
has been recognized by researchers for
decades now
curcumin is a pigment found in turmeric
that not only gives it its
characteristic bright hue but also
provides a range of health benefits
turmeric has been studied in relation to
arthritis eye conditions cancers heart
diseases alzheimer's disease and much
more
recently a study involving
2478 people was done to find a
correlation between turmeric use and
lung function
the results showed that turmeric intake
was associated with improved lung
function
also the improved lung function was
proportional to the curcumin intake
level
in fact high curcumin intake in smokers
was associated with up to 9.2 percent
better lung function compared with
smokers who did not consume curcumin
so adding turmeric to your diet might
just be the boost your lungs need for
good health it will not only add flavor
to your diet but also bring a wholesome
goodness as well
if you'd like to know more about
turmeric make sure to subscribe to our
channel as we are going to upload a
video on this topic very soon
the number second superfood for lung
health is beetroot
beet root which is a reddish delightful
salad we all love is a superfood
beet and beet greens have been shown to
benefit lung function
this is because beet is packed with
nitrates and nitrates are very important
for healthy arteries
they relax the blood vessel walls which
decreases blood pressure and effectively
increases oxygen intake all of which can
help someone struggling to breathe
this is especially important in people
with lung conditions like copd and
pulmonary hypertension a disease that
causes high blood pressure in the lungs
beets are also packed with vitamins and
nutrients that can promote lung health
like magnesium vitamin c carotenoids
antioxidants and potassium
now why potassium is important is a very
simple answer potassium helps in
reducing water retention which prevents
fluid buildup in the lungs
the most common source of potassium is
bananas spinach broccoli mushrooms beets
and other green leafy vegetables
so make sure to include these foods in
your diet
number three on the list are vitamin c
rich foods
in our previous videos we have talked
about how oxidative stress damages the
organs its blood supply and hinders the
recovery process
antioxidants are the antidote to this
damaged one of the most important yet
easily available source of antioxidants
is vitamin c
vitamin c is a water-soluble nutrient
that acts as a powerful antioxidant
getting enough vitamin c is especially
important for those who smoke
according to a 2015 study in people with
adequate vitamin c intake lung function
is favorable even in smokers
cigarettes are terrible for your body
since they have a negative effect on
your antioxidant source so it's
important that people who smoke
to increase their intake of vitamin c in
their diet
a 35 milligram per day vitamin c intake
is shown to be beneficial
some of the richest sources of vitamin c
include peppers plums
cherries guavas blackcurrant parsley
spinach kiwis and
obviously lemons and citrus fruits like
oranges
and berries
if you would like to know more about how
vitamin c helps your body boost your
health and more you can click the banner
above or go to the link in the
description below we have made a video
on this topic and i'm sure you will like
it
number four on the list are carotenoids
and other antioxidants
carotenoids are the pigments in plants
of red yellow and orange color you may
ask why a color giving pigment comes on
this list for lung beneficial foods
well carotenoids are vital antioxidants
for humans let me give you an example
lycopene
lycopene is a carotenoid antioxidant
which is associated with improved lung
health and what is the richest source of
lycopene the bright red lucious tomatoes
eating tomatoes can help reduce
inflammation in people with asthma and
lung disease
a survey was done in 2015 to find a link
between the dietary intake of
antioxidants and 10 year lung function
they found that eating plenty of
antioxidants like those present in
fruits and tomatoes was linked to
healthier lungs even when you're getting
older they also stated that this
association was especially strong in
smokers who had quit a 2019 study was
done among the patients with asthma at
al-shifar medical complex in gaza strip
palestine its aim was to identify major
dietary patterns and their association
with the level of asthma in those
patients
they found that a prudent pattern of
diet was associated with a lower
prevalence of asthma this prudent
pattern was characterized by high intake
of whole grains
beans and legumes
fish and shellfish products vegetables
tomatoes fruits and healthy vegetable
oil
all of these are highly dense sources of
helpful carotenoids
some of the other antioxidant rich foods
that you can start including in your
diet are pumpkins
pumpkins contain a wide variety of lung
health promoting plant compounds
these include carotenoids such as
beta-carotene lutein and zeanthene
blueberries are also rich sources of
anthocyanins including malwaredin
cyanidine peonitin delphinidin and
petunin
these are good to consume if you want to
keep your lungs healthy
cabbage especially red cabbage is also a
rich source of anthocyanins additionally
it is a rich source of fiber which also
helps to detox the body
ademy beans are a great source of
isoflavones eating high isoflavone diets
may reduce the chance of getting various
diseases including copd a 2010 study was
done to find a relation between lung
function changes and traditional
japanese food the japanese diet is high
in soy products and fish which are
excellent sources of isoflavones and
helpful fatty acids
the results state that isoflavone also
improved the shortness of breath
number five on the list are coffee and
cocoa
coffee is a wake up drink for billions
of people worldwide every morning its
effect are attributed to caffeine which
is found in coffee tea cola drinks and
cocoa a recent research has shown that
caffeine might also act as a wake-up
drug to boost your lung health
a 2010 research studied the effect of
caffeine in people with asthma
the results stated that caffeine appears
to improve airway function modestly for
up to 4 hours in people with asthma
this is attributed to its ability to
dilate airways and blood vessels which
improves airflow and oxygen exchange
leading to decreased symptoms even
though the effects are temporary
it is here that we can also talk about
the benefits of cocoa
if you are a health conscious person
then you may have heard about the health
benefits of cocoa and cocoa products
like dark chocolate
they contain a compound called
theobromine which helps to relax the
airways in your lungs a 2019 study was
done to find a link between cocoa intake
and overall health in university
students
the author suggests that cocoa's
potential health benefits are due to its
high polyphenol content
this is attracting much attention due to
its potential cardio protective
anti-inflammatory anti-obesity and
neuroprotective actions which are
positively reflected in peoples who
regularly consumed cocoa
now what about our lungs well to find
this out in 2018 an extensive research
was carried out in more than 55 000
adults
the results of this study were published
in a paper known as dietary intake of
flavonoids and ventilatory function in
european adults
the study showed that increasing the
consumption of dietary sources of
flavonoids can contribute to maintaining
lung function
and can also prevent its decline
the study found that those who consumed
more flavonoids found in foods like
chocolates for example had stronger
lungs versus those with lower intake
high time you start indulging on
chocolate but be careful excess of
everything is harmful
well friends with this we come to the
end of this video i hope i have given
you some new and exciting facts and
knowledge if you like today's video
don't forget to share it with your
friends and family if you are new to our
channel consider subscribing if you like
our content we admire simplified always
appreciate your support and feedback
consider becoming a member of our
youtube channel or patreon community
as always take care and i'll see you in
the next video